ouvert en mai dernier dans le cadre du
plan cancer de poissy la maison les
trois arches accueillait aujourd'hui du
public pour sensibiliser et informer
contre le cancer c'est une maison qui
est dédié aux patients atteints de
cancer et aussi aux proches aux proches
aidants c'est une maison qui propose des
soins de support en ce n'est pas une
maison médicale c'est une maison on va
dire qui permet d'avoir des ateliers
notamment de socio-esthétique de l'epic
aux logiques sophrologie atelier
alimentation aussi réinsertion
professionnelle aussi au programme
stands d'informations avec des
psychologues des travailleurs sociaux
des associations ou encore des
diététiciens nouveau trois heures c'est
vrai qu'on parle plutôt de soutien
psychologique c'est vraiment s'il ya une
étape de leur parcours le le patient à
patient 302 faisant vraiment d'échangé
d'avoir s'étend des changes pour eux où
ils se remettent au centre aussi et pas
juste sur un versant de soin médical
et puis l'intérêt aussi de ce dispositif
ce qu'on entend beaucoup par rapport aux
personnes qui fréquentent les trois
arches si l'on vit aussi de rencontrer
d'autres personnes c'est un lieu
centralisé où ils peuvent venir où ils
peuvent se sentir en temps de jeu
compris et où ils sont pas forcément
d'avant ils sont pas forcément dans
l'hospitalière l'occasion de rappeler
aussi en pleine campagne octobre rose
l'importance du dépistage du cancer du
sein octobre rose c'est un mois de
sensibilisation pour le dépistage du
cancer du sein l'idée c'est de rappeler
que c'est important de se faire dépister
le plus tôt possible pour essayer de
traiter le mieux possible la maladie on
a beaucoup de d'activité on a eu des
marches on a donc des flash mobs on a
des conférences enfin ya tout un tas
d'activités qui sont là pour rappeler ce
mois qui étreint à moi indispensable au
dépistage du cancer du sein d'autres
actions sont prévues au cours du mois à
poissy dont des stands d'information et
des espaces des changes il 12 21 et 29
octobre prochains